Today we're going to be turning to Leviticus and Leviticus is a primary document
of the priestly school and we identify this work as priestly because it deals
with matters that were of special concern to and under the jurisdiction of
priests.
The sanctuary.
It's cultic rituals,
the system of sacrifices,
the distinction between the holy and the profane and the pure and the impure.
So the priestly materials are found as a block in Leviticus,
large part of numbers and then they're scattered throughout genesis and exodus.
And because of these common themes,
we say that they were produced by a priestly school.
Um,
we hypothesize a priestly school,
we don't quite clearly understand exactly what that means and who and exactly
when these materials emerged over a period of centuries that's clear.
They reached their final form in the exilic or post exhibit period.
But they certainly often preserve older Celtic traditions and priestly
traditions as well.
We can break the book of Leviticus down into the units that are listed on that
side of the board.
You have in chapters one through seven,
the sacrificial system,
chapters eight through 10 recount.
The installation of Aaron is high priest and the era nights.
Then as the priestly clan within Israel,
chapters 11 through 15 covered the dietary system,
the dietary laws as well as the rituals,
purity laws.
Chapter 16 describes the procedure to be followed on the day of atonement or Yom
Kippor chapters 17 through 26 then our a block of material that's referred to as
the holiness code because of its special emphasis on holiness.
So most scholars think that that block of material comes from a different
priestly school.
And so we designate that h holiness,
the relative dates of p and h p now meaning the non h parts of the [inaudible]
materials,
they're much debated,
but I think increasingly the consensus is that h the block and material in the
video 17th through 26 and then also with its got passages scattered around other
parts of the Bible.
But the consensus increasingly is that h is later.
It's a redactor or editor of the other priestly materials.
So p is a difficult term of reference because p can refer to the entirety of
priestly writings all together.
But when we sing about h and talk about age,
then P in contrast to h means the priestly writings that are not age.
So maybe small p and a capital p.
I don't know.
Now the priestly materials have for a long time been I think a devalued part of
the Hebrew Bible and scholarship of the 19th century.
And most of the 20th century is generally characterized by a deep seated bias
that views impurity rules as primitive and irrational taboos and sacrifice as
controlled savagery that's empty of any spiritual meaning.
Religion without such rights is evolutionarily superior or higher and more
spiritually meaningful.
And with those kinds of attitudes,
it's not difficult to understand why,
um,
scholarship on Leviticus and those parts of the Bible tend to be rather
dismissive.
In the latter part of the 20th century,
this situation began to change as anthropologists and ethnographers began to
study the danger avoidance practices of many cultures,
the taboos and rituals of many cultures including modern western culture,
new avenues for understanding the danger avoidance practices of the Bible began
to emerge.
And the anthropologist,
Mary Douglas Changed Forever the way scholars would approach the impurity rules
of the Bible because she insisted on their interpretation as symbols,
symbols that conveyed something meaningful to those who followed them.
Biblical scholars like Jacob Milgrom and more recently,
Jonathan [inaudible] attuned to developments in the social sciences have made
very great advances in our understanding of Israelite purity practices.
They've tended to view the elaborate and carefully constructed texts of p as
part of a system whose meaning derives from the larger cultural matrix or grid
in which those materials are embedded.
How much the system laid down by p represents what ordinary Israelite Judeans,
uh,
thought and did,
how much these rules were actually enacted and followed how much they drew upon
older random practices,
brought them together,
modified them,
and posed some semblance of order upon them.
How much they represent just the ideal construction or blueprint of an elite
group.
These are all unanswerable questions.
The fact is,
no one really knows,
but we do know from living cultures that people do engage in all kinds of ritual
and symbolic actions because of genuine beliefs about the importance of those
actions.
Because those rituals and symbols are extraordinarily meaningful to them.
And in any event,
our primary concern is with the program of the texts as they stand before us.
Is there a symbolism operating here?
What are the key ideas and the key themes of the priestly material?
How do these ideas,
how,
how does this material jive with other aspects of Israelite religion that we've
talked about so far?
What ultimately is the purpose toward which these materials are aiming well,
like the rest of the ancient world,
Israel had a cultic system and that cultic system featured a sanctuary,
the sacred space with holy objects,
sacred objects where priests performed a variety of ritual acts.
So Israelite Judean religion on the ground shared many cultic forms and
practices and rituals with Canaanite and ancient near Eastern culture.
Generally sanctuaries in the ancient world were understood to be the dwelling
place of the deity.
Sacrifices were offered to the deity in his or her sanctuary.
P describes a portable sanctuary and Mishcon that's used in the wilderness
period.
And if you look on your handout,
there's a reconstruction of this tent,
like a sanctuary,
um,
at the top,
as well as the Schema desertion of its contents below.
So woven curtains hung from wooden frames that could easily be assembled and
disassembled.
And these curtains surround the sacred precincts who see that in the top
picture.
And within those precincts,
within that enclosure,
there's a large open courtyard that was accessible to all Israelites.
The main sacrificial official alter with a large ramp stood in that courtyard as
well as a basin that was therefore ablutions.
And then halfway across the courtyard,
there was a screen that mark the entrance to another little enclosure,
which is the shrine proper,
the sanctuary proper.
And only priests have access to that area.
Um,
the shrine or sanctuary housed and incense altar.
And then on one side,
a seven branched lamp stand or Menorah and on the other,
a table which held loaves of bread that were changed on a weekly basis.
The back most square-shaped chamber of that inner shrine was the inner sanctum
or the holy of holies.
And that was accessible only to the high priest and only on the day of atonement
following a series of heightened purity observances inside that holy of holies
was,
the Ark was about four feet by two and a half feet.
It was a wooden arc covered in gold on top was a kind of covering.
It's referred to as a corporate.
We don't really know what this word means.
It's traditionally translated mercy seat.
I think that's how the jps might translate it.
Um,
but at some kind of gold cover.
And then there were two Cherubim,
these enormous winged lions that flanked the Ark,
likely they were connected to that,
that mercy seat cover.
If so,
then what they were was a throne.
And we have an ancient near eastern iconography Thrones of this type.
We have pictures of gods and kings seated on these seats,
the sides of which are these giant wing to Cherubim and then their feet rest on
a footstool.
Likewise in some biblical verses.
God,
yeah,
halfway is described as enthroned upon the Cherubim.
Um,
the Ark then is said to serve as his footstool.
So that's sort of the box that he would have rested.
His feet on.
The Ark itself contained the tablets of the covenant.
And so it was a testament to the covenant between God and Israel.
Interestingly,
unlike most ancient sanctuaries,
the Israelites Sanctuary did not contain a statue of the deity.
And that's I think,
evidence of the very strong,
an iconic tendency of Israelite religion.
Nevertheless,
God was believed to be present in the sanctuary,
often in the form of a cloud that will fill,
it will descend to fill the tabernacle,
um,
particularly as it's assembled in a new encampment.
Um,
and then God will descend down to the cloud.
We'll fill the tabernacle.
So it is God's presence there that sanctifies,
which simply means makes holy,
makes sacred to sanctify,
to make holy the tabernacle.
And to understand this,
we need to understand the priestly conception of holiness.
Now the Hebrew word holy has a root meaning of separate.
Separate that which is holy is separate.
It's withdrawn from common,
everyday use.
In the priestly view,
only God is intrinsically holy.
Intrinsically Holy God.
Can Impart Holiness to,
he can sank defy persons and places and things when they're brought into a
specific kind of relationship with him.
Our relationship that's best described as a relationship of ownership.
What is holy is what is in God's realm.
Something that's separated to him,
that which is outside God's realm is common.
Or the Hebrew word for common is sometimes translated by the English word
profane.
Um,
that has a negative connotation in English,
but in fact,
it really doesn't bear that negative connotation.
Profaned simply means not wholly,
not sacred.
We use it differently now.
Um,
but the fact is that the common or profane state is the natural default state of
most objects and things.
This table is,
is just profane.
It's common.
It's available for everyday use.
It's not separated or marked off for special kind of treatment.
Um,
because it's,
it's holy for a common object to become holy.
You need a special act of dedication to God,
an act of sanctification to transfer the thing to God or God's realm or God's
service.
So holiness entails necessarily separation in both its positive and negative
aspects.
That entails separation of an object to that which sanctifies it,
which is God,
and it involves separation from in the form of safeguards against anything that
would threaten to remove its sanctity.
So separation from that which threatens its sanctity.
Holy things are holy because they are removed from the realm of the common by
means of rules or safeguards that demarcate them as different and separate and
determine that we use them differently.
The preservation of holy status therefore depends on those rules and safeguards
there.
Observance protects the holy object from profit nation,
from being profaned,
reverting from holy status back to common status.
Now it's evident from the schematic representation or the way I've described the
sanctuary that holiness increases as you move deeper into the sanctuary.
And the principle here is that holiness increases as proximity to God increases.
The principal is graphically demonstrated in spatial terms.
So in the biblical view,
if the area or the land outside the Israelite camp is just common profane land,
these are like camp bears a certain degree of holiness.
Then as you move in the outer court yard,
the outer enclosure,
the sanctuary,
there's a slightly higher degree of holiness.
It's accessible to Israelites who are pure,
the sanctuary proper,
which is in closer proximity to God.
Bears are still higher degree of holiness.
It's accessible only to the priests who are said to be the holy ones within
Israel.
And then the inner shrine is the holiest area.
It's accessible only to the holiest member of the nation,
the high priest.
You have similar concentric circles of holiness characterizing the priestly
conception of time.
There are ordinary common profane days,
work days.
Then there are certain holy days,
for example,
the new year or the Passover holidays.
That's where our word holiday comes from holy days,
and they are separated and demarcated from common time by special rules that
mark them as different,
holier than these days is the sabbath,
which is demarcated by even further rules and observances and the holiest day is
Yom Kippor known as the Sabbath of sabbaths.
This day is separated from all other days by additional rules and observances
and keeping with its profound holiness,
the holiness of persons,
of objects of time and of space all converge on Yom Kippor because it's only on
this most holy day that the most holy person,
high priest enters the most holy of holies,
the inner most shrine,
and performs a ritual upon the most holy of objects,
the mercy seat and Ark itself once a year.
Well now we need to consider the deep connection that exists between holiness
and purity because the two are not identical despite massive amounts of
scholarship that confuses this issue.
Thinks holy means pure,
thinks common means impure,
and it just doesn't.
These are different binary oppositions.
The two are not identical to be holy means to belong to or to be in the realm of
God.
Things can't become holy and can't come into contact with the holy or the sacred
if they are not first pure purity,
which is the absence of impurity,
is a prerequisite for access to the holy or for holy status.
To be in a state of purity simply means that one is qualified to contact the
sacred right to enter the sacred precincts,
to handle sacred objects and so on.
To be in a state of impurity simply means that one is not qualified to contact
the sacred.
So if you're an impure at home and just minding your own business,
it's no big deal.
It's only a problem if you decide you want to go to the sanctuary.
So purity and impurity are states of qualification or disqualification for
contact with Sancta.
The holy is by definition pure by definition only that which is free of impurity
can contact the holy if an impure object.
And you'll see here these overlapping pairs,
which are also in your handout.
If you could imagine the lower pair of sort of being clocked down on top of this
pair,
that will give you an idea of what we're trying to convey with this image.
Okay.
Things are either wholly or common,
but if they're holy,
they must be pure.
Common objects can be pure impure.
Just depends whether or not they've been in contact with a source of impurity or
not.
All right,
if,
but notice that the holy and the impure or never conjoined.
If an impure object comes in contact with a holy object,
then the holy object is immediately defiled.
It's immediately rendered and pure that were defiled means to take on some form
of ritual impurity,
and it loses its holy status automatically.
So it becomes both impure and profane
to be restored.
Then you're going to have to have two things happening.
First of all,
it's gotta be purified.
Got To get rid of the ritual impurity.
So they'll have to be some ritual procedure that purges the impurity.
So once you've done that,
you've made it pure,
but it's still common profane.
So it has to,
if it's to be made holy again,
it has to be read,
dedicated,
or given over to God.
Again,
re sanctified,
maybe a little holy anointing oil,
pour it on it.
That's one means of sanctification.
Simply handing it over to God,
elevating it towards God is another way of re sanctifying something.
But it there has to be two steps,
uh,
purification and then a sanctification to make it holy again.
Increased access to the holy requires increased an increased degree of purity.
It's the connection between holiness and purity.
So the purity that's required of a priest who has access to the sanctuary proper
is higher than that of an Israelite who has access to the outer courtyard.
Only the purity required of the high priest is even greater.
So to be pure,
one must separate oneself from sources of impurity.
What are the sources of impurity?
And I hope you've had a chance to look at,
um,
the reading material because I'm going to go through this relatively quickly.
Jonathan [inaudible] has been the most vocal proponent of the claim that
biblical texts speak of two distinct types of impurity,
ritual,
impurity and moral impurity,
which I have up here.
Um,
you've read this short article he has in the Jewish Study Bible,
but he's also written about this at great length in other places.
And according to klons and others,
ritual impurity arises from physical substances and states which are not in
themselves sinful.
There's no intimate connection with sin.
When we're talking about ritual impurity,
in fact,
a lot of ritual impurity is unavoidable and sometimes even obligatory,
right?
Um,
sexual contact makes one ritually impure,
and yet God commands humans to be fruitful and multiply.
I'm burying the dead.
Makes one ritually impure,
but God commands proper care of the debt.
So there's nothing inherently sinful about contracting.
Ritual,
impurity,
ritual,
um,
which is generally permitted is distinguished by the characteristics I've
quickly jotted down here.
It's contagious.
That is,
it's transferred to other persons or objects.
Um,
depending on how receptive they are.
perhaps by physical touch,
perhaps in the case of severe impurity,
by sharing an enclosed space,
by being together of,
over and under an overhanging roof or tent.
Um,
ritual impurity is also impermanent.
It can be removed or reduced through rituals of,
of ablutions or just the passage of time or other sorts of ritual observances.
Ritual,
impurity also defiles or renders and pure sancta.
And so it has to be kept separate from sancta in very severe cases,
it can even to file some common objects.
And in those cases,
the source of impurity might have to be isolated or excluded,
um,
if necessary.
Now,
the concept of ritual impurity was a central and integral feature of most,
if not all ancient religions and the biblical laws of purity and impurity
strongly resemble those of other ancient near eastern cultures,
Egyptian,
Mesopotamia,
and even Hittite culture.
And certainly there are ancient near eastern and Canaanite routes for Israelite
purity practices.
But the system of ritual purity and impurity that is crafted in the priestly
writings of the Hebrew Bible represents an attempt to monetize the eyes,
to monitor the eyes,
Israelite purity practices,
and to create a system that differentiated Israel from her close neighbors.
So for example,
impurity was often connected with belief in evil spirits and impure demons.
It's quite possible that Israel's purification rituals may have originated and
even long endured as,
um,
rituals of exorcism that expelled a demon or who was believed to be causing the
affliction and question that may be their origin as source.
But in the priestly writings,
impurity is generally divorced from any association with evil spirits.
Some scholars theorize that the ritual purity system reflects an original
concern with health or hygiene,
but this isn't very convincing.
Only one set of diseases is said to generate ritual,
impurity and many substances that are widely considered unhygienic by most
cultures.
For example,
human and animal excrement.
And these are not sources of ritual impurity to Israel's priests.
So [inaudible] is among those who insist that any effort to understand the
purpose and the meaning of Israelite purity practices as schema ties by the
monetizing priestly writers in Leviticus 12 through 16.
And again,
whether actual Israelite Judeans did this or understood things this way,
we'll never know.
But to understand the schema causation of,
of the monetizing scheme,
mitigation of Israel's purity practices,
we would do better to ignore questions of origins and to attend to the larger
symbolism of impurity and holiness.
In these writings in particular,
we need to try to understand the antithetical relationship between impurity and
holiness.
The two are opposites.
They are opposed and antagonistic towards one another.
So [inaudible] points out as you know that there are three main sources of
impurity in p,
first of all,
um,
corpses.
And certain carcasses are a source of ritual impurity Sarrah Act,
which is this,
we translate it scale disease,
it's been called leprosy.
It's definitely not leprosy.
Um,
people who know such things have read the details in the biblical text and it's
not what is truly known as leprosy,
but at some sort of skin disease,
flaking,
skin disease or other sorts of boils and,
and skin states that seem to be associated,
at least in the Israelite mind with decomposition and death.
We have a couple of passages.
One in the book of numbers,
one in the book of job which described this condition in a way that identifies,
that identifies it with death.
Um,
uh,
an aborted fetus is often described as looking like it has this condition.
For example,
I'm not often happens once in the book of job,
but the point is there's a connection between this condition,
the skin condition and its decomposition and death.
The third source of ritual impurity would be genital discharges,
both normal and diseased [inaudible] notes in the article you read that the
physical substances and states that are labeled impure and are therefore
designated as antithetical to the realm of holiness are states that are
associated with death on the one hand and procreation on the other.
Why should this be the priestly conception of God?
You will recall is of an immortal and asexual being.
Think back to the first creation story,
which is the priestly creation story.
To enter the realm of the holy in which there is neither death nor procreation
requires a separation from death and procreation.
It is association with death and sexuality that renders one impure and
disqualifies one from entering the holy sanctuary.
That is not to say that one shouldn't deal with death or sexuality in the
ordinary course of life.
On the contrary,
God explicitly commands humans to be fruitful and multiply,
and he does that in the piece source,
right?
In genesis one,
he commands proper care of the dead and he also does that in the piece source.
It simply means that one cannot enter the holy sanctuary.
God's realm when impure through contact with death or sexuality.
So according to [inaudible],
ritual purification involved separation from those aspects of humanity,
death and sex that are least godlike to enter God's realm requires imitation of
God or imitates c o d right?
An idea that I've put up here imitates dod imitation of God,
and Cohen's further argues that the concept of [inaudible] Day,
he also explains the practice of sacrifice,
which on the face of it contradicts the idea that you must avoid death and
connection with the holy,
right,
because sacrifice entails killing right in the sanctuary killing of animals,
right in the sanctuary.
So [inaudible] argues,
and I quote,
that sacrifice involves in part the controlled exercise of complete power over
an animal's life and death,
which is he says precisely one of the powers that Israel's God exercises over
human beings as God is to humanity.
Humans in imitation of God are towards their domesticated animals.
So the process of sacrifice,
I won't go into his argument here,
but flow ons develops a strong argument that the process of sacrifice can be
understood itself as an act of [inaudible] because sacrifice involves a variety
of behaviors in the biblical texts that are analogous to behaviors attributed
elsewhere in the biblical text to God.
I'm the care and feeding and raising of domestic animals,
the selection of one that is deemed a perfect control over it's life and death
and so on.
And these were all spoken of in terms that are analogous to terms used to
describe God as the shepherd of his flock of Israel and in control of life and
death and so on.
So Colandra I used at the process of sacrifice,
which grants the offer a complete control over life.
And death is a kind of imitates cod.
But Kawana also asserts,
and I quote,
that emitted CEO Day,
he does not exhaustively explain sacrifice in ancient Israel.
And in fact,
we should be surprised if any one single theory would indeed explain sacrifice.
So he just says that there are really two organizing principles are overriding
concerns in the priestly traditions and the priests in materials regarding
sacrifice.
The first,
as we've seen is [inaudible],
but the second is a desire to attract and maintain the divine presence,
the continued presence of God in the sanctuary.
The majority of the sacrifices that are described in the opening chapters of
Leviticus in Leviticus one through seven are voluntary sacrifices.
These are sacrifices that are offered as gifts or in times of celebration.
Put a little list of them up here,
but uh,
the first three are the ones that will concern is now we have,
first of all,
the whole offering or burnt offering.
It's sometimes called,
this is when an animal is entirely burned to create,
as the text says,
a pleasant smelling odor or pleasant smelling smoke that ascends to God.
So according to p,
the priests are to offer to such burnt offerings with pleasing smelling odors to
the Lord every day,
one in the morning and one in the evening on a regular basis from the community.
The second kind of offering that's described as the grain offering.
This is a gift of flour and oil and incense,
which is burned after a portion is removed for for the priests as dues to the
priest.
The rest is burned on the altar again with a sweet smell from the incense.
Third,
we have a set of offerings known as well being offerings,
peace offerings.
It's sometimes translated.
These offerings are generally consumed by the offer and the F and his family.
Very often in a festive or situation as a big feast after certain portions are
donated to the priest.
Again,
wellbeing offerings,
sort of three main types.
You had the Thanksgiving offering,
you have a freewill offering just because someone wants to do this,
a freewill offering and you have a vow offering that would be offered on the
successful completion of a vow,
for example,
and these sacrifices are all entirely optional.
They were offered in celebration.
They were offered at Thanksgiving or upon the successful completion of a vow.
In other words,
the sacrificial cult was primarily a vehicle for worshipers,
expression of a wide range of emotions,
joy over the birth of a child,
um,
thankfulness for a good harvest and so on.
Now,
texts from ancient near eastern cultures suggest that essential function of the
rituals that were performed in sanctuaries was to secure the perpetual aid and
blessing of a well disposed deity and in important ways,
the Israelite cult is strikingly similar,
particularly in the sacrifices I've just described.
The Israelites certainly hoped to secure the perpetual aid and blessing and
protection of a well disposed deity blessing and benefaction flow from God's
presence in the midst of the community,
in his sanctuary.
When he is there,
there is blessing.
So [inaudible] follows earlier scholars in suggesting that the rituals and
sacrifices performed in the sanctuary,
we're designed to ensure God's continued residents within and blessing of the
community.
In particular,
the daily burnt offerings sacrificed by the priests twice each day and emitting
this pleasing odor.
These were an effort to attract the deity.
Likewise,
the gifts,
the other foods and pleasing odors of the sacrifices brought by individual
worshipers attracted and maintained.
The continued presence of God in the sanctuary.
So this is the second overriding concern,
organizing principle of the sacrifice,
not simply that there should be in potassium a day within God's realm,
but also that the activities there should attract and maintain the presence of
the DVD for the wellbeing of the community,
but just as God is attracted by certain kinds of behaviors.
So he is repelled by others and in the priestly system,
grave sins generate and impurity.
Now a moral impurity.
So now we're coming to the second kind of impurity,
a moral impurity that repels the divine presence.
Okay,
so moral impurity is the second kind of impurity that's described by [inaudible]
and others.
In contrast to ritual,
impurity,
moral impurity does arise from the commission of sins.
Ritual impurity does not.
It's nothing that's prohibited about it's you never told not to become ritually
impure,
okay?
There's nothing sinful about it inherently,
but moral impurity arises specifically from the commission of certain heinous
sins.
Specifically the three that I've listed here are the biggies.
Idolatry,
alright,
homicide and sexual transgressions.
These are spelled out in Leviticus 18 and Leviticus 20.
Those two chapters besides defiling,
the sinner,
moral impurity symbolically defiles various sancta,
especially the sanctuary,
but also God's name and also the Holy Land itself.
Moral impurity differs from ritual,
ritual,
impurity,
not simply because of its origin and sin,
but also in the fact that it's not contagious,
right?
You don't contract impurity by touching a murderer.
The way that you can tract ritual impurity by touching somebody,
um,
with the gonorrhea,
okay?
Also,
moral impurity is not removed or we do civil through rituals through washings
and launderings ritual,
ablutions and the like.
Um,
that does not touch moral impurity and a person moral purity of persons can be
achieved only by punishment for heinous sins.
Uh,
for example,
the punishment of corate or cutting off is a divine punishment.
Being extricated from the house of Israel or death,
right?
That's one way to be rid of moral impurity.
Um,
also,
it can be achieved or by simply avoiding or abstaining from the filing immoral
acts in the first place.
That's another way to achieve,
um,
moral purity.
Also,
if you atone for,
um,
unwitting sins that you perhaps later realize and regret,
acknowledge and confess,
then that can also have reduced moral impurity.
Very severe moral impurity defiles the innermost,
the inner most areas of the sanctuary as well as the land.
Now,
the sanctuary can be purified of moral impurity,
and I'll come back and talk about that in a second.
But the land really cannot land that is repeatedly defiled or the Holy Land of
God that is repeatedly defiled by sexual transgressions,
for example,
um,
cannot be purified.
Eventually it will simply vomit out the from the biblical text says,
it will simply vomit out those who dwell on it as a reference to exile.
This is consistent with,
um,
the representation of the expulsion of the Canaanites from God's land.
Remember when God said the sin of the Amorites is not yet complete?
When they have sinned so much into to such a degree,
they will be vomited out and then your tendency can begin.
The land will purge itself of the impurity by vomiting them out.
And this is consistent.
Then with the repeated warnings in Leviticus to the Israelites not to engage in
similar abominable and sinful practices.
The sexual transgressions,
the bloodshed,
the idolatry because they too will pollute the land until it vomits them out.
They will be expelled.
The land is also defiled by elicit homicide.
There is legal homicide of course,
judicial death and so on in the Bible,
but elicit homicide,
whether intentional or unintentional,
tensional murder or accidental homicide.
The man's slayer bears blood guilt.
What is referred to as blood guilt.
That's a kind of moral impurity and his life,
his forfeit.
Because of that,
in cases of deliberate murder,
blood gill and impurity are removed only by the death of the murderer himself,
only blood atones for blood.
In cases of accidental homicide,
the perpetrator can take refuge in one of five cities that are designated for
this purpose,
the five cities of refuge,
they can live there until the death of the high priest and the death of the high
priest symbolically serves to purge or remove the blood guilt or impurity of the
accidental homicide.
Idolatry also to files the land offenders are subject to stoning and the divine
penalty of carrot of cutting off the Bible repeatedly warns that idols and their
cultic appurtenances must be completely destroyed from the Holy Land,
right?
The Israelites have to eradicate that they're polluting the land.
Now in contrast to the land,
God's sanctuary can be purified from moral impurity by means of a special
sacrifice.
And this is the fourth sacrifice listed here.
The Habitat,
um,
which is uh,
the purification sacrifice.
It's often erroneously translated as a sin offering.
It's better translated as a purification offering.
How does it operate the blood of the animal?
The blood of the sacrifice is the key to the whole ritual.
Remember that impurity and sin are often associated with death.
Holiness that which is holy is often associated with life.
And if the two are antithetical,
then it makes sense.
If impurity is associated with death,
it makes sense that it's antipathy.
Antithesis.
Holiness would be associated with life according to the priestly source blood,
the blood that courses through one's veins represents the life force.
Remember in the Noaa Hide Covenant in Genesis nine,
which is a priestly passage,
the priestly blood prohibition,
you may not spill human blood and you may not eat animal flesh that has the
lifeblood in it because the blood is the life and that belongs to God.
That's wholly right.
So the life force is holy and the life forces in the blood.
Leviticus 17 verse 11 says this,
it repeats the blood prohibition and then it offers a rationale for the life of
the flesh is in the blood.
And I have assigned it to you for making expiation for your lives upon the
altar.
I've assigned it to you to use in sacrificial practices.
It is the blood as life that affects expiation,
purging and atonement.
So the priestly texts couldn't be clearer.
Blood represents life.
The blood of sacrificial animals is assigned by God as a detergent,
if you will,
to cleanse the sanctuary of the impurities that are caused by the sinful deeds
of the Israelites.
Sacrifices at purge the sanctuary of ritual impurity and primarily the hot tub.
Um,
always involve the manipulation of the animal's blood,
dabbing it on the altar and on Yom Kippor actually entering the innermost shrine
and sprinkling it on the throne of God and the footstool,
the Ark itself,
it symbolizes the victory of the forces of life,
of and holiness over death and impurity.
Other purified Tory rights that are listed in the Bible will sometimes involve
the use of reddish substances as a kind of surrogate of blood.
It's a widely,
um,
and it is widely and mistakenly thought that the purification offering purifies
the sinner or the impurity bear or the offer.
This can't be true.
The habitat,
the purification offering doesn't rid a ritually impure person of their ritual.
Impurity,
you can't even offer a sacrifice unless you're already ritually pure because you
couldn't get in to the sanctuary to offer your sacrifice if you weren't ritually
pure.
You can't approach to offer a sacrifice if you're not in a state of ritual
purity already.
So purification offerings are brought after the genital g discharge has,
has healed and passed after the scale disease has healed and passed after the
appropriate ablutions have been observed.
And the person is essentially pure,
but there's one more step they have to take before they're integrated back into
the community.
But cut tat also does not rate a sinner of their moral impurity because the
offering is brought after the center has confessed after the sinner has
repented.
The purification offering acts on the sanctuary not on the offer.
It purges the sanctuary of the defilement that is symbolically.
It has symbolically suffered from the offers state of ritual,
impurity or sinfulness.
Once the sanctuary is purged,
the offer has settled his debt.
He's repaired the damage he caused.
He's fully atoned at one again with God and God is no longer at repelled by the
impurity that marred his sanctuary.
The defiling effect of lesser transgressions is calibrated to the sinners
intentionality and the presence or absence of repentance.
So inadvertent sins can be purged.
The this sanctuary defilement that they cause can be purged by bringing a
purification sacrifice.
What about deliberate sins?
As long as there is repentance,
the biblical text says then they are converted into inadvertent sins and they
also can be purged or the impurity they cause can be purged with a purification
sacrifice,
but brazen,
unrepentant sins,
unrepented sins or unintentional sins that are never realized.
These stand on remedied and they defile the sanctuary.
So for this reason the sanctuary has to be regularly purged of the accumulated
defilements accruing to it.
As a result of such.
Since Leviticus 16 describes the annual ritual which is carried out on the day
of Atonement or day of purgation,
it can be called Yom Kippor.
When a coup d'etat sacrifice of purification sacrifice is brought on behalf of
the community to purify the sanctuary of the impurities that have been caused by
Israel's sin and the high priest loads all of the sins and impurities of the
Israelites on the head of a goat,
which then carries them off into the wilderness away from the sanctuary.
Purification of the sanctuary was believed to be critical to the health and the
wellbeing of the community.
If the sanctuary is not purged of impurity,
it can become polluted to the point when God is driven out entirely.
Jacob Milgrom has argued that there's a kind of archimedean principle at work
here.
Every sin creates an impurity that encroaches upon the realm of holiness and
displaces a certain amount of holiness,
and eventually God will be completely displaced and the community will be left
in a godless state without blessing or protection.
So Milgrom sees the symbolic function of the purity system.
This way,
if the sanctuaries symbolizes the presence of God,
and if impurity represents the wrongdoing of persons,
then by saying that impurity is anathema to God and pollutes his temple,
the priests are able to graphically convey the idea that sin forces God out of
his sanctuary and out of the community.
Jacob Milgrom sees a moral message at the base of this complex symbolic picture,
and that is that human and humans and humans alone are responsible for the reign
of wickedness and death or the reign of righteousness in life.
Human actions determine the degree to which God can dwell on earth among his
people.
So the goal or the objective of the priestly construction or representation of
Israel's impurity laws was in Milgram's view to sever impurity from the demonic
and to reinterpret it as a symbolic system,
reminding Israel of the divine imperative to reject sin,
to behave in ways that attract the presence of God and do not repel him.
You also read an article by Milgrim where Milgrom talks about,
um,
priestly cultic imagery serving as a kind of theodicy,
a theodicy of course,
as a response to the problem of evil.
How can an all powerful,
good God allow so much evil to exist and even go unpunished?
And according to Milgrom,
this is the priestly answer.
Every sin pollutes the sanctuary.
It may not mark the sinner,
but it does mark the sanctuary.
It scars the face of the sanctuary.
You may think you've gotten away with something,
but every act of social exploitation,
every act of moral corruption pollutes the sanctuary more and more until such
time as God is driven out and human society is,
is devoured by its own viciousness and death dealing.
So again,
the ethical message here is that humans are in control of their destiny and they
action of every individual affects and influences the fate of society.
This is really the priestly version of an old biblical doctrine of doctrine,
of collective responsibility.
Sin Affects individual sin affects the entire fabric of society.
There's no such thing as an isolated evil.
Our deeds affect one another,
and when evil doers are finally punished,
they bring down others with them.
Those others,
however aren't.
So blameless Milgram's says,
because they allowed the wicked to flourish and contribute to the pollution of
the sanctuary,
the corruption of society.
So ps cultic imagery is informed according to Milgram by the same communal ethic
that we will see running through the Bible.
Much of the Bible until a later period is simply conveying that ethic in its own
modality.
Through the symbolism of the sanctuary and the cult.
The 11th chapter of Leviticus deals with the dietary laws.
We don't have time to go into them at any great length.
I will say that Milgrom has also argued that the dietary laws of Leviticus are
similarly part of a symbol system that emphasizes life over death.
This is his file.
The following evidence that he cites.
The mainstays of the dietary laws are these first the prohibition against eating
animal blood from genesis nine,
um,
which symbolizes the life.
We also in Leviticus 11 meet dietary laws that are governed by criteria such as
cud chewing and having a split hoof.
You can only have eight animals that chew the Cud and have a split hoof.
And those criteria seem arbitrary and meaningless in and of themselves.
And he says they are.
But look at their practical effect that limits the number of animals that one
can eat to a mere handful out of the hundreds upon hundreds of creatures on the
earth.
That basically leaves you with my animal.
Husbandry is not good here,
but it leaves you with a bovine and the Ovi classes I guess.
Oh,
and our goats and,
and some such.
So it leaves you basically with goats and sheep and cattle.
Um,
some have hypothesized that whatever the origin of various food taboos in
Israel,
the priestly techs have tried to create a dietary discipline that drives home
the point that all life shared also by animals is inviolable except in the case
of meat,
which has been conceded by God and provided that the animals are slaughtered
properly,
painlessly,
uh,
and that their blood,
which is symbolic of the life is not appropriated but returned to God.
It's sacred source.
So perhaps as it stands,
this system of dietary laws does in fact emphasize reverence for life,
but they also serve another very important function.
And that was the formation and maintenance of a differentiated ethnic identity.
Or in priestly parlance,
the formation and maintenance of a holy people separated out from other nations
by rules that marker as God's people,
it's surely significant that the dietary laws are followed by a powerful
exhortation to be holy in imitation of God.
Leviticus 1143 45.
So we've just had the prohibition of,
of not eating certain kinds of small animals designated here as anything that's
swarms.
And the tech says,
you shall not draw Obama nation upon yourselves through anything that's swarms
you shall not make yourselves in pure there with and that's become impure for I
the Lord your God.
You shall sanctify yourselves and be holy.
For I am holy.
You shall not make yourselves in pure through any swarming thing that moves upon
the earth for I the Lord and he who brought you up from the land of Egypt to be
your God.
You shall be holy for I am holy.
That how much this is emphasize,
the dietary laws are presented by the priests,
not as a hygienic regimen.
Who knows if that's how they started,
not as a sensible way to avoid various diseases that are caused by the lack of
refrigeration in the desert.
Whatever the actual origin of these various dietary to booze,
they are here embedded in a larger ideological framework concerning the need for
the Israelites to separate themselves and to be holy like their God.
The dietary laws are connected then with this theme of [inaudible] Day of
Imitation of God as God is holy,
separate and distinct,
so you shall be holy.
He just want to take too last minutes to quickly point to this theme of holiness
that continues in the section I'm referred to as the holiness code cause this
theme and the exportation you shall be holy for I the Lord your God am Holy.
They find their fullest expression in the block of texts,
Leviticus 17 through 26 that's referred to as the holiness code.
There's an important difference between Leviticus one through 16 and the
holiness code.
According to Leviticus one through 16 Israel's priests are designated as holy,
a holy class within Israel singled out,
dedicated to the service of God and demarcated by rules that apply only to them.
Israelites may aspire to holiness,
but it's not assumed.
However,
in the holiness code,
we have texts that come closer to the idea that Israel itself is wholly by
virtue of the fact that God has set Israel apart from the nations to himself to
belong to him.
Just as he set apart the seventh day to himself to belong with him.
Holy things only exist because of safeguards.
Rules that keep them separate,
the demarcate them.
And these safeguards and rules are naturally addressed to human beings.
They are the ones charged with the task of preserving the holy in its residents
on earth.
So although holiness derives from God,
humans have a crucial role to play in sanctification and sanctifying the world.
That's illustrated in the case of the Sabbath.
God's sanctified the sabbath,
that creation,
he demarcated it as holy,
but Israel is the one to affirm its holiness by observing the rules that make it
different to that market office.
Holy.
So Israel doesn't just affect affirm the holy status of the Sabbath.
They actualize the holy status of the Sabbath.
If Israel doesn't observe the prohibitions that distinguished the Sabbath of Sa
as sacred,
it's automatically desecrated.
You shall keep the Sabbath for it is holy for you.
He who pro feigns it shall be put to death.
Whoever does work on it,
that person is cut off from among his kin.
You automatically,
it is automatically desecrated and profaned if you don't observe its rules.
So there are two components,
integral and inseparable,
and the concept of holiness.
Initial assignment of Holy Status by God and establishment of rules to preserve
that holy status.
And secondly,
actualization of that holiness by humans through the observance of the
commandments and rules that marks that thing off his holy.
That's going to lead us very nicely into an understanding of the laws that mark
off Israel's status and keep Israel distinct among the nations,
which we'll be looking at on Wednesday.
So please take a look at the materials that were sent out,
the ancient near eastern collections and some of the questions to guide you
through this material.